bonjour et bienvenue dans ce stade
science consacrée aujourd'hui au
réchauffement climatique
pas question ici de ressasser des
arguments usé jusqu'à l'os le châtiment
je leur ai dit c'est le châtiment
monsieur pourriez vous en parlant de ce
nous allons justement voir ce que les
connaissances paléontologique c'est
géologique peuvent nous apprendre sur
les climats du passé et répondre ainsi à
une question qui n'est finalement que
très peu posé le réchauffement
climatique
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé avant non
plus tôt mais non j'ai dit plus tôt
beaucoup plus tôt pour retrouver les
traces d'un réchauffement climatique
comparable à celui qui porta je ne sais
pas ce qui m'arrive la même oui
peut-être oui pour retrouver les traces
d'un réchauffement climatique donc
comparable à celui qui a lu aujourd'hui
il faut remonter à la fin du paléocène
au niveau de la petite flèche rouge là
il y à 56 millions d'années un événement
s'est produit et il s'appelle le pote me
non pe tm pour maximum thermique
paléocène eocène c'est un événement de
réchauffement climatique intense
survenue à la fin de l'époque paléocène
d'après les estimations basées sur des
analyses chimiques des sédiments
à cette époque la température s'est
élevée d'approximativement six degrés en
moins de vingt mille ans ça n'a l'air de
rien mais une augmentation de 6 degrés
c'est ce que les estimations les plus
pessimistes nous prédisent rien que pour
l'horizon 2100 nous sommes donc en passe
de battre ce record à plate couture
alors quelles ont été les conséquences
biologiques de ce bouleversement
climatique et bien à une extinction en
grand nombre des espèces animales et
végétales qui vivait à cette époque les
extinctions d'ailleurs été si nombreuses
que les paléontologues ont choisi de
placer à cet endroit la fin de
l'époque paléocène exactement de la même
manière que la crise d'extinction de
masse survenue il ya 65 millions
d'années a marqué la fin de l'époque
précédente le crétacé alors se
dirige-t-on vers une nouvelle extinction
de masse
en fait selon certains spécialistes nous
y sommes déjà
l'homme par ses activités et la
destruction des habitats est déjà le
responsable de ce que certains
n'hésitent pas à appeler la sixième
grande crise d'extinction
10 proton mort pour sa viande le to do
more pense à viande morte pour sa viande
ledoux payante bord pour des clous le
thon rouge pas encore mort mais ça va
pas tarder
mais souriez car toutes les conséquences
d'un réchauffement climatique ne sont
pas catastrophiques
ça fait mal de sourire
certaines espèces comme les kids et
irako terium s'en sortent sans trop de
bobos ne voyant que leur taille diminuer
durant quelques générations sous l'effet
de la restriction des ressources
alimentaires d'autres même s'en sortent
extrêmement bien comme le petit
mammifère herbivore basket mais attends
là c'est pas parce qu'à terium sa ch à
wemmel et les chatons j'ai quand même
plus mignon ça plus de succès sur le net
quand il faut sinon ouais bon donc
pascal terium lui s'en sort même très
bien puisque sa représentation dans les
gisements fossilifères de cette époque
explose littéralement
il se trouve qu'il a su tirer profit des
conditions de la crise c'est un
opportuniste de crise en quelque sorte
enfin certains primates des
représentants de notre propre famille en
profiter que la chaleur effet cet ordre
les forêts tropicales jusqu'au pôle pour
se répandre d'un continent à l'autre et
donc qui a pas que du mauvais dans une
crise d'extinction de masse et notre
propre évolution ne s'est faite qu'au
profit de l'extinction d'autres groupes
comme les dinosaures par exemple et les
gaz à effet de serre vous êtes vous déjà
demandé si nous étions les premiers
animaux à reproduire en telle quantité
des chercheurs ont fait pour vous raillé
par leurs confrères ils ont proposé que
les gigantesques dinosaure herbivore qui
vivait au jurassique
on peut produire une très grande
quantité de gaz à effet serre qui aurait
été en grande partie la cause du
réchauffement climatique au temps des
dinosaures
et comment donc en roulant dans des
grosses voitures
mais non en platine ont été déjà si tu
dit ou fait une blague pipi caca je te
jure avant rasoir d'accord d'accord je
ferais rien car en effet les gaz émis
par les grands herbivores le méthane
notamment agissent comme de puissants
gaz à effet de serre et les dinosaures
on aurait produit des centaines de
millions de tonnes par an mais dis donc
c'est quoi cette image
qu'est-ce que je t'avais dit c'est juste
une image qui a renoncé aux choses
sérieuses
d'autres organismes ont déjà provoqué la
pollution de leur atmosphère bien avant
les humains ou les dinosaures
il s'agit des bactéries il y à plus de 3
milliards d'années avant cette époque
l'oxygène et est très rare dans
l'atmosphère voire même inexistant ils
n'étaient produits que par des bactéries
microscopiques qui étaient alors les
seuls êtres vivants sur la terre
primitive
ces bactéries comme les arbres
d'aujourd'hui fabriquer de l'énergie par
photosynthèse grâce à l'énergie solaire
elle n'avait pas vous en oxygène pire
l'oxygène était un poison à déchets
métaboliques produit par la
photosynthèse et oui pour les premiers
êtres vivants l'oxygène n'était pas du
tout bienvenue car l'oxygène est
impuissante agent destructeur
sarah connor c'est quoi
l'oxygène est capable de détruire les
métaux les plus résistants et il est
responsable des réactions chimiques les
plus violentes comme la combustion la
rouille et le feu sont des réactions dit
d'oxydation et les premières cellules
vivantes ville oxygène comme la crise
car tous ceux qui l'approchent y compris
les êtres vivants se retrouvaient
détruit par l'oxydation
mais voilà devenant de plus en plus
nombreuses les bactéries produisirent
assure plus d'oxygène et alors elle ne
purent pas survivre à cette pollution
généralisée celle celles qui pouvaient
tolérer une très grande concentration de
ce poison et surtout celle qui surent
tirer parti de la réaction d'oxydation
survécurent ces êtres vivants venait
d'inventer la respiration
les autres victimes de l'oxydation
disparurent il ne resta plus que des
organismes tolérant voir respirant
l'oxygène
tant et si bien qu'aujourd'hui imaginez
un monde où la vie pourrait s'épanouir
en l'absence d'oxygène nous est devenu
complètement invraisemblable et c'était
pendant les conditions initiales de la
vie ainsi par le jeu de la sélection
naturelle les êtres vivants s'adapte à
la pollution
ils survivent d'abord malgré elle est
finalement finissent par vivre grâce à
elle le poison devient alors terreau
combien avez vous lu d'écureuil de
renard de s'ennuyer de rats de pigeons
vivre en fouillant dans les poubelles ou
même de mouettes ni celle en haut des
charges
saviez vous que les arbres des villes
polluées ne meurt pas mais au contraire
grandissent plus vite grâce au surplus
de co2 il ya toujours une place pour les
opportunistes
le vix ne peut pas être contenu de la
vie prend le large la vie conquièrent de
nouveaux territoires elle traverse
toutes les barrières c'est parfois
pénible c'est parfois dangereux mais
c'est comme ça alors concernant le
réchauffement climatique
il ne s'agit pas seulement de savoir si
l'ours polaire survivra mais il s'agit
bel et bien de savoir si notre propre
espèce survivra à elle même car par
définition lors d'une extinction de
masse ce sont toujours les espèces
dominantes qui disparaissent si les
mangas
ses stats science s'achève merci de
l'avoir suivi pour en savoir plus sur le
réchauffement climatique
regardez par votre fenêtre et
réfléchissez à ce que vous y voyez
merci à tous